♪ ♪ ♪nenenenenenenenenenenenenee
restaurant sans âme d'un centre
commercial de LaSalle,
des symboles de la culture
ouïgoure ont trouvé refuge.
traditionnels ouïgours,
aux instruments de musique,
comme le rabab ou le dutar,
non sans douleur, ses originesài
la Chine, in extrémis,nfnfnfnfn.
TURSUN ROUZI, propriétaire,
restaurant Ozgu Uyghur Cuisine
- Euh... J'ai... arrivéau Canad.
Cinq années, ma soeur,
Rien, je n'ai pas parlé, rien.
Ma soeur..
mon frère.
- Ces quelques photos,
c'est toutzazazazazazazazazazaze
de membres sont portés disparus.
"Ma famille est en prison,
torture et violence physique et,
moi, je vis dans un pays libre
comme le Canada, mais ma douleur
Otage dans un pays libre
pour qui la pilule des Jeux
olympiques ne passe pas.
Même s'il dit aimer les Jeux
olympiques, il ne comprend pas
pourquoi on passe
de la personne en Chine.
- (homme): Stop genocide!
- La cause ouiààààààààààààààààà.
KAYUM  c c c c coordonnateur ONG
Uyghur Rights Advocacy Project
- On compte certaines familles
qui comptent à peu près
40 p p p p p p p p p p p p p p s
disparues. Aucune nouvelle
pendant les derniers 4-5 ans.
- La Chine a durci
ses pratiques
l'ensemble de sa population;
les voix chinoises dissidentes
sont emprisonnées,
selon ce professeur en droit.
RENÉ PROVOST, professeur,
Faculté de droit Univ. McGill
- Les Ouïgours, qui font l'objet
de mesures
à des violations massives
et systématiques des dro
de la personne. Il y a aussi
le Tibet qui continue;papapapaps
les mêmes pratiques de...
d'effacement des cultures
minoritaires et des langues
minoritaires continuent.
- À Hong Kong, la loi sur
la sécurité nationale a muselé
toute opposition à la ligne
politique go
GUY HO, militant,
mouvement Free Hong Kong
- Il y a eu des mesures
répressives contre
la démocratie, les droits l l li
de la libertsesesesesesese
à Hong Kong. C'est vraiment
incroyable que...uxuxuxuxuxuxux.
- Le Canada fait partie
des rares pays occidentaux
qui ont décidé d'un boycottage
diplomatique des Jeuxééééééééééé
de purement symbolique.
- À certains égards,
c'est vrai que c'est symbolique,
mais par ailleurs, ça s'atta
sont eux-mêmes un symbole.
Et la raison pour laquellerrrrrr
les Olympiques chez elle,
c'est justement le symbole
de l'importance, sinon de
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui.
- Tursun a choisi la cuisine
ouïgoure pour transmettre un peu
de sa cultur
pour apprendre celle
de sa terre d'ac
- ..............................
a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a r
sa famille, Tursun projette
de grandes
ses enfants. Son fils joue
déjà dans l'équipe de soccer
Sa fille envisage des études
universitaires en sociologie
après son cégep.
Radio-Canada, Montréa